[Música]
y
falta menos de una hora para que se
cierren las urnas en colombia este
domingo 39 millones de ciudadanos están
llamados a votar para elegir entre seis
candidatos a la presidencia la
polarización el incremento de la
violencia y la tendencia del aspirante
izquierdista gustavo petro a ser el más
votado marcan los comicios
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr se le
esquí y salió de la región capital por
primera vez desde que comenzó la guerra
desde jarc y despidió al jefe de
seguridad regional por no proteger a la
segunda ciudad más importante del país
luego de su visita se escucharon
explosiones en esta ud
tres mil policías israelíes han sido
desplegados en jerusalén de cara a una
marcha de ultranacionalistas ésta
atraviesa el barrio musulmán en la
ciudad vieja y los palestinos la
consideran una provocación ya se
registraron disturbios en la mezquita de
al-aqsa
bienvenidos a la actualidad
internacional aquí en france 24 los
saluda maría clara calle
empezamos en noticias latinoamericanas a
las 4 de la tarde -hora local- cierran
los puestos de votación en colombia
donde se celebra la primera vuelta de
las presidenciales si bien el padrón
electoral es de 39 millones de
ciudadanos históricamente cerca de la
mitad de los votantes se abstienen las
encuestas señalan que ninguno de los
seis aspirantes obtendría más del 50 por
ciento de los votos que se necesita para
ganar este domingo lo que obligaría a
una segunda vuelta el 19 de junio además
todos los sondeos muestran que el
candidato gustavo petro es quien
obtendría más votos lo que acerca a
colombia a tener un presidente de
izquierda por primera vez en su historia
los otros aspirantes son federico
gutiérrez de derecha sergio fajardo por
el centro el independiente de rodolfo
hernández además de milton rodríguez y
enrique gómez
y en la primera mitad de la jornada de
estos comicios en colombia se
registraron 119 reportes de posibles
irregularidades y delitos electorales
según lo denunció la misión de
observación electoral una organización
independiente colombiana que verifica lo
que ocurre en todas las votaciones esto
luego del manto de duda que cubrió los
pasados comicios al congreso y es que el
escrutinio de esa votación del 13 de
marzo tardó más de una semana y en
algunos casos la diferencia con el
preconteo fue tanta que varios
congresistas perdieron el escaño que
inicialmente habían ganado múltiples
políticos respondieron pidiendo la
renuncia del registrador nacional
alexander vega quien sigue en su cargo
por eso conversamos con mauricio vela
coordinador del observatorio político
electoral de la democracia de la moe
previamente nos explicó qué ocurrió en
esas elecciones y cuál es el impacto en
las presidenciales
el problema aquí va para las elecciones
de congreso tuvo que ver con el
preconteo otros que es un proceso
meramente informativa es decir esto no
son los votos reales que cuentan
finalmente para los curules del congreso
sino es para informar el día de las
elecciones cuál ha sido más o menos el
panorama de la votación estuvo un
problema con la transmisión de datos
donde muchos votos para algunas campañas
políticas no se transmitieron y por lo
tanto no se reportaron y por lo tanto
ese cambio tan radical entre el
escrutinio el preconteo esto claramente
generó problemas en la confianza en la
registraduría y por lo tanto por la
registraduría estuvo en estos últimos
meses haciendo un poco de medidas y
mesas técnicas para mejorar todo lo que
tiene que ver con el proceso electoral y
está en forma evitar que se repitan los
mismos problemas para estas elecciones
lamentablemente se perdió mucho la
confianza en la registraduría y el
proceso electoral y esto pues es un
agravante bastante preocupante de cara a
lo que pueden ser los resultados tanto
de primera y segunda vuelta acá
claramente la rectoría de proveer las
garantías y dar todos los pasos
necesarios para que las campañas
políticas reconozcan en legitimidad este
proceso
cada ser si se quiere un gran esfuerzo
no sólo el día de hoy sino también las
próximas semanas si llega la segunda
vuelta de manera que mejore toda esta
confianza en el proceso electoral las
presidenciales en colombia llegan además
con el transfondo de un incremento de la
violencia en los territorios más
golpeados por el conflicto y el abandono
estatal desde la firma del acuerdo de
paz entre el estado y la extinta
guerrilla de las farc en 2016 al menos
mil 306 líderes sociales han sido
asesinados indígenas campesinos
población afro y desmovilizados de las
farc son el principal blanco de ataque
sólo en 2022 mataron a 79 líderes además
de 21 firmantes del acuerdo de paz hasta
la fecha colombia ha sufrido 44 masacres
sólo en el departamento del cauca los
grupos armados ilegales han asesinado a
12 líderes en el último año esta región
es una de las más letales para los
defensores y hasta allí viajaron marina
sardiña y lionel pus débil quienes nos
traen el siguiente reporte
antes de su asesinato salió una amenaza
firmada supuestamente por los
paramilitares donde salía el nombre de
miller y otros líderes amenazando los
supuestamente por el tema político
electoral posicionarse políticamente le
costó la vida al consejero indígena
miguel correa uno de los 12 líderes
sociales asesinados en el departamento
del cauca colombia en lo que va de año
dura muñoz su compañera mantiene el
anhelo de un cambio a las amenazas
constantes da temor
que pueda repetirse la historia
pero pues
es ahí donde yo digo hay que hacer todo
lo posible todo lo que esté en nuestras
manos y más allá en los últimos cuatro
años la deriva para las comunidades
indígenas campesinas afro y
desmovilizados de las farc fue el
incremento de la violencia en su contra
es observado aún más en las regiones
donde operan los grupos armados
respaldados por el narcotráfico los
cultivos ilícitos la minería ilegal el
acaparamiento de tierras y el abandono
estatal favianca mayo miembro de la
guardia indígena se recupera de un
ataque de las disidencias de las farc e
surgieron después del acuerdo de paz de
2016 el mismo grupo asesinó a dos de sus
hermanos uno de ellos el popular líder
de la guardia indígena albeiro para mayo
para el conflicto se agudizó aún más
dentro del territorio en el gobierno de
el presidente duque pues hace como como
a un lado deja la dejación de los
acuerdos de para no y creo que es más
donde se incrementa el tema
de los cultivos de uso ilícito se
incrementa el tema de los grupos armados
y referente eso pues también se agudiza
el tema de la muerte de los líderes
social pese al dolor su madre velina
mantiene la esperanza de que la paz se
refleje en todas las comunidades los que
votaron los que no votaron pero algunos
comuneros y entonces son unos como forma
de una familia y que toca que mirarse a
todos clemencia carabalí líderes socio
feminista con más de una docena de
amenazas en su contra se siente por
primera vez representada en una
candidata surgida de las mismas
violencias que muchas liderezas padecen
a diario el ver que en medio de la labor
tan difícil que hacemos de un contexto
tan complicado
vemos que si se puede escuchar y
trabajar con las voces de los
territorios es lo que exigen al próximo
presidente colombiano estas comunidades
de las regiones más golpeadas por el
perpetuo conflicto armado son parte de
las voces en profundo descontento que
por primera vez en la historia podrían
llevar a un triunfo a la izquierda en
estos comicios los invitamos a que se
conecten con nosotros hoy a partir de
las cinco de la tarde en bogotá ciudad
poquito y lima tendremos nuestro
especial sobre las elecciones
presidenciales en colombia allí
conoceremos los resultados el análisis y
la información con nuestra red de
periodistas y con la conducción de mi
compañero andrés meza muñoz
cambiamos de noticia suben a 56 los
muertos por las fuertes lluvias en
brasil según el más reciente reporte del
gobierno del estado de pernambuco además
las autoridades todavía no encuentran a
otras 56 personas la mayoría de estos
desaparecidos se concentran en las
ciudades de recife la capital del estado
y en olinda casi 4.000 personas quedaron
sin hogar y es que desde el sábado ha
habido deslizamientos de tierra
provocados por los torrenciales que
afectan a varios estados del noreste de
brasil
desde la escuela donde se perpetró el
tiroteo más mortífero en casi una década
en eeuu el presidente joe biden y su
esposa jill se reunieron con los
familiares de las 21 víctimas la
principal queja es que la policía se
tardó más de 45 minutos en entrar al
aula donde estaba el tirador a lo que el
departamento de justicia de
estadounidense respondió este domingo
que investigará a la acción de los
uniformados la pareja presidencial
también asistió a la vigilia por los
muertos en balde
esta visita se da un día después de que
la vicepresidenta kamala harris fuera a
buffalo en nueva york' para el sepelio
de las víctimas de otro tiroteo que
ocurrió en un supermercado allí volvió a
hacer un llamado a los legisladores para
que prohíban las armas de asalto
vamos a europa por primera vez desde que
inició la guerra en ucrania el
presidente de ese país volodymyr
selenski salió de la región capital y
visitó a jarquín la segunda ciudad más
importante allí despidió al jefe de
servicio de seguridad regional por no
protegerla en los primeros días del
conflicto cuando los rusos se
concentraron en bombardear a jarquín y
antes de que las tropas de kiev los
replegarán después del viaje del
mandatario se escucharon varias
explosiones en la urbe juan pabló lucumí
nos cuenta más de esta visita
es la primera vez que el presidente
ucraniano visita una de las zonas más
golpeadas por la guerra
volodymyr selenski llegó este domingo a
jarque para discutir la posibilidad de
reconstruir nuevas viviendas en la
azotada zona del este del territorio
ucraniano según el gobernador cerca del
30% de la segunda región del país está
bajo posesión rusa y más de 2.100
bloques de apartamentos han sido
destruidos por las tropas de moscú
tenemos que encontrar dinero y líneas de
crédito porque las ciudades los
gobernadores y los alcaldes tienen más
posibilidades de encontrar uno u otro
programa europeo para la construcción de
viviendas algunos programas estatales y
otros locales como su primera salida de
la capital desde la invasión rusa el 24
de febrero se leen que también visitó a
las tropas desplegadas en el frente de
batalla las felicito y les mostró su
apoyo
previamente el mandatario pidió a eeuu y
a sus socios europeos más apoyo en
tecnología antiaérea para lograr hacerle
frente a la ofensiva rusa que ha
enfocado sus esfuerzos en el donbass de
una y otra vez recordarle al mundo que
rusia debe ser finalmente reconocida
oficialmente como un estado terrorista y
un estado patrocinador del terrorismo
esto es simplemente cierto es honesto y
refleja la realidad cotidiana que los
ocupantes han creado en ucrania y están
deseando llevar a europa mientras que el
gobierno ucraniano anunció su victoria
ante la ofensiva rusa en severodonezk un
sector clave en la región de lugansk el
ejército ruso se jactó de tener el
control sobre el imán una ciudad del
este de ucrania cuyo control abre la
puerta sobre el dominio del donbass
en noticias de medio oriente
los israelíes celebran hoy una fecha a
la que los palestinos tildan como una
provocación en la llamada marcha de las
banderas los ultranacionalistas festejan
la anexión que hizo israel de jerusalén
este en 1967 una ocupación a la que la
comunidad internacional cataloga como
ilegal gabriel coll chen nos cuenta el
origen de esta fecha en
1967 estalló la guerra de los seis días
que enfrentó a israel y a tres de sus
vecinos egipto siria y jordania tras el
conflicto israel tomó el control de
varios territorios entre ellos jerusalén
este la parte este de la ciudad paso de
control jordano a israel y una ocupación
calificada de ilegal por la comunidad
internacional es un lugar de mayor
importancia religiosa tanto para los
musulmanes como para los judíos ya que
alberga la explanada de las mezquitas
tercer lugar más sagrado para el islam y
que los judíos llaman el monte del
templo el más sagrado del judaísmo
si el día de jerusalén marca la
liberación de la ciudad para los judíos
los musulmanes ven esta celebración como
una provocación anata lado figuró móvil
de firma estatal a las incursiones del
enemigo sionista y su marcha de las
banderas es como echar leña al fuego el
pueblo palestino se ha movilizado para
formar un muro que impida al enemigo
sionista llevará a cabo su planeada
invasión de la mezquita de al-aqsa
el domingo hoy estamos celebrando el día
de jerusalén durante el día habrá muchos
eventos incluida la tradicional marcha
de las banderas en su ruta habitual pido
a los participantes que celebren de
manera responsable y digna y desde aquí
en nombre de los ministros del gobierno
israelí envió un gran agradecimiento a
la policía y los oficiales de la policía
israelíes por asegurar todos los eventos
a la baja está vinculado en 2021 las
tensiones entre el ejército israelí y
las milicias palestinas en la franja de
gaza durante la celebración iniciaron la
mayor escalada bélica entre las partes
desde
1967 que dejaron 243 muertos en el lado
palestino y dulce en el lado israelí
también se mueve el mundo de las
noticias deportivas y es que este
domingo terminó el giro de italia con
una victoria sorpresiva el australiano
ya hay ingle del bora jasgur se quedó
con la maria rosa tras la contrarreloj
de hoy sin embargo fue el sábado cuando
sacó la ventaja sobre el ecuatoriano
richard cara paz quien liderado al giro
con un minuto y 25 segundos por encima
de sus contendores pero sin live tuvo un
poderoso final en esa etapa de montaña
lo que le permitió llegar con confianza
a la fase final de hoy a pesar de que
cara paz fue más rápido en verona
yingling se convierte así en el primer
australiano en ganar el giro de italia
además los invitamos a que consulten
toda la información de nuestra página
web veamos lo que tenemos a esta hora en
france 24 punto com donde cubrimos con
nuestra cobertura especial las
elecciones en colombia allí tendremos
análisis de cuáles son los puntos claves
de estos comicios presidenciales y
además uno de los mayores retos que
tiene el próximo presidente de colombia
consolidar la paz
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que sigan conectados con nuestra
programación
[Música]